ruth báder ginsburg fue pionera en la
lucha por los derechos de las mujeres un
activismo que le llevó en 1993 a ser
jueza de la corte suprema y que el 25 de
septiembre tras morir a los 87 años le
sirvió para convertirse en la primera
mujer y la primera persona judía en
recibir un funeral de estado
empecé con profundo pesar y profunda
simpatía por la familia kings ver tengo
el gran honor de dar la bienvenida a la
jueza ruth báder ginsburg para que
permanezca en el capitolio de eeuu este
primero su cuerpo permaneció en el
capitolio y después fue enterrada en el
cementerio de arlington un homenaje para
un icono que ha inspirado a millones de
mujeres en eeuu
otra activista maría durán y sigue
avanzando en los derechos de las mujeres
afganas en la región conservadora de
kandahar ha abierto un gimnasio para
mujeres al que suelen ir 50 cada día
tenemos muchos problemas pero después de
muchos años silenciadas nuevamente
estamos luchando por conseguir derechos
para las mujeres es una lucha que lleva
mucho tiempo días faltaban bajas además
del gimnasio durán y dirige una radio
para mujeres es representante política y
michelle obama le otorgó el premio
internacional mujeres valientes en 2012
[Música]
la pandemia ha acelerado la educación
virtual sin embargo en muchos lugares no
todas las personas pueden acceder a un
ordenador como en méxico donde la ong
laptops con causa recoge viejos equipos
para repartirlos entre estudiantes
entonces con esto pues no se pudo no
tengo una computadora y todo lo manejado
por el celular entonces me va a servir
muchísimo porque va a hacer también que
mis tareas y mis trabajos gracias sean
mucho más rápidas hasta el momento este
grupo ha conseguido entregar 70
ordenadores y tienen 300 donantes
potenciales aunque la demanda continúa
siendo de miles
ye mi sillón es un coleccionista de arte
nigeriano su objetivo consiste en poner
en valor su colección en nigeria para
que la población se siente orgullosa en
un momento de gran reputación
internacional de dos formatos rich
sandwich airbag ocho años promovamos la
riqueza y la belleza de nuestra cultura
yo uso mi colección de arte como un
medio para mostrar nuestro pasado y
nuestro presente así como la capacidad
de mirar hacia este pasado y este
presente de forma que ayude a las
personas a comprender el futuro su pib
grand stand de fitur durante 44 años si
ya han acumulado siete mil obras de arte
mil fueron donadas a la universidad para
atlantic o de lagos y desde septiembre
han sido expuestas al público en un
intento por reivindicar el arte local
[Música]
cuac hollande ya es una fundación y una
reserva en puebla mexico se trata de un
retiro para 88 caballos que han sido
víctimas de maltrato y explotación
después de ser decomisados por las
autoridades llegan a este refugio para
poder vivir con dignidad y así por fin
puedan tener la vida que nunca tuvieron